something crazy is going on
so on twitter my what's happening
section it's this curated feed that
appears on the right side of the screen
all of a sudden skateboarding is
trending
baseball is trending ubuntu is trending
and i'm like i like those things
baseball's kind of mad but i like
skateboarding and i like linux why is
skateboarding trending the entire time
i've been on twitter or at least for the
past seven or eight years it's been
completely political there was even this
one period where twitter was trending a
story that was about me that had no
track no traction no no interest and it
was completely fabricated
now all of a sudden
the trending is cleared up
something dirty is happening behind the
scenes at twitter
and i think there is now ample evidence
suggesting that twitter is cleaning
house and trying to purge nefarious code
i think perhaps vijaya gaday was crying
in the meeting because they lied to
congress about what they were doing
behind the scenes
personally i think twitter was
suppressing right-wing accounts and
creating fake left-wing accounts for the
sake of healthy conversations right
trying to create some kind of pseudo
balance now i'll present my case for
this it is just a hypothesis i i won't
say it's definitive because i don't know
for sure but that's how things really
seem
amid this
all of these shenanigans with elon musk
buying twitter biden's dhs has announced
a new ministry of truth it's actually
some kind of department of battling
disinformation but
sure it's being run by some woman who is
lamenting elon musk's takeover someone
who is basically a russia gate proponent
so we can see where this is going
they are not just going to back down
we've now got journalists claiming elon
musk is already in breach of contract
for buying twitter because he disparaged
twitter
surprise surprise he's not they're lying
once again
senator hawley is calling for a
censorship audit on the platform
we got to talk about this stuff we've
got a bunch of other stories maybe we'll
get to we've got
illegal immigrants now in the united
states i think over a million
we've got a new op-ed from stephen marsh
on civil war saying abortion may be a
may be
like a large catalyst for as we've
talked about it before but i don't know
if we'll get to all of that because so
much is going on with what with this
twitter stuff it is not just about
censorship anymore it looks like there
may be some serious enron level illegal
or malfeasant
goings-on at this company and elon musk
as jack bosovic said bought the evidence
so
joining us to discuss all this today is
cheryl atkinson
would you like to introduce yourself
hello i'm cheryl atkinson
and
my voice is a little funky today
but i think we can hang in there you
want to pull the mic up a little bit and
you can you can keep your you know keep
it down yeah just rest your voice and
take it easy and
we'll keep that coming
i have a long time establishment
journalist
working for cnn and cbs and pbs
before going out on my own
and i tend to cover a lot of media
issues sort of looking at my own
industry in a critical way that
i think is very healthy but a lot of
other journalists tend not to do
right on well thank you for coming it
should be interesting considering what
we're dealing with now uh
already there are journalists trying to
lie and cover up we've got this guy from
nbc saying twitter says the the flux and
followers is all organic sure we've got
jack zoev hanging out
the number one trend in the united
states of america now is the ministry of
truth because earlier today nobody was
talking about this dhs disinformation
governance board
until i happen to be on twitter someone
sends me this thing
that it's nina jankowicz uh who's in
charge of this thing nina jankowicz you
may know her uh from previously calling
and saying that trump supporters were
planning to show up at the polls on
election day militarized and with
weapons to intimidate people from going
to the polls that's her october 2020 on
cnn saying that previously she was a
member of a harry potter fan band known
as the the moaning myrtles uh who had
their that's a scandal who had lyrics
that i don't think i can say on uh on
youtube um about you know obviously
underage boys um yes i'm serious and no
one was talking about this other than
the fact that she very obviously leaked
the news to politico and then was you
know crowing about this
and for some reason politico didn't even
think to do a story on the ministry of
truth that was being enacted
by the biden administration so it was up
to little old me to have to go tweet
this out and all the receipts of nina
jankowicz who she is what they're doing
because tim and everybody else here i
got to say this and cheryl it's amazing
i do hope you feel better but i'm really
honored to be on with you tonight
that
she is one of the people who immediately
when she saw the hunter biden laptop
story
said that it was russian disinformation
she said it was uh it was a fairy tale
that he could have left his laptop in
this delaware tech shop because you know
never heard of a crackhead losing
something before um
this is the person who's now in charge
of your ministry of truth wow all right
well jax thank uh thanks for joining us
thanks for being here
also by pillow by pillow
by pillow i'm i'm just buying
my favorite just buy the pillow i keep
being surprised if there's political
pushback against elon buying twitter
when
just before it was vanguard blackrock
and morgan stanley that owned a quarter
of the company and i never heard anyone
mention that
so i i don't know what's better off in
the hands of one man like jeff bezos
and the washington post is it better off
in the hands of a multinational
corporation and you decide anyone other
than vanguard state street blackrock et
cetera et cetera bezos yeah yeah
all right we also got lydia pressing the
buttons i am here pushing buttons i had
a great conversation with um cheryl
earlier this evening i'm really
optimistic hoping her voice holds out
for us tonight hopefully we can make it
the whole show we'll see what you can do
before we get started my friends head
over to stronger bones and life and pick
up your ageless multi-collagen from
biotrust you can secure your supply of
ageless multi-collagen up to 51 off why
do you need it well if you are starting
to get old it's good for your joints
your hair your skin your nails it'll
keep you looking young and supple and as
i skate all the time we are out on the
uh we got we got a new seven foot um
vert wall it's sort of vert you know
it's like you ever see skateboarders go
up the half pipe that's what we got and
so we're getting big air and we're
falling down we're getting hurt we got
to keep our knees healthy so i got to
eat this ageless multi-collagen just
head over to stronger bones and life.com
and you'll get a 60-day money-back
guarantee the healthy aging support of
collagen and its ideal forms five key
types of collagen you need from four
different sources for every order today
they will donate a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org today
biotrust has provided over 5 million
meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-gmo and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and rbst
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth there's no clumping you'll get
free shipping with every order free vip
live health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order again
that's over at strongerbonesandlife.com
shout out biotrust and don't forget head
over to timcast.com
in the top right you will see that
beautiful sign up button sign up to help
support our journalists and the work we
do
we recently put up a billboard in times
square calling out the washington post
for lying with your support we will
continue to call out the establishment
for their lies and everything we're
seeing right now yo we are we are
storming the hill with the daily wire
building culture with what we've been
working on with our journalists with the
show we do here challenging them
challenging the mainstream press and the
lies every night
and then putting up a billboard with the
help of the daily wire i think it's a
white pill moment it's it's it's it's
good times good times ahead but this is
a battle being won the war is not over
so go to timcast.com become a member and
you'll get access to exclusive members
only segments of this show monday
through thursday at 11 pm we'll have one
up for you tonight but don't forget to
smash that like button right now
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and let's jump into
the first story i'd like to show you
this tweet from elon musk it is a meme
it's a meme of me
and boy did this one trigger a lot of
people man but it's not so much about
the meme i i do want to highlight it
shows me say here's an example of
twitter's left-wing bias twitter says we
need to take into consideration the
context me then saying
the context is affected by your bias and
then twitter's saying we need an example
of that and the cycle continues and i
give you another example well tim
do people understand that this actually
comes from your appearance with her on
joe rogan because i i actually think
people may not understand the concept
well i think a lot of people don't
understand that this is just summarizing
i went on joe rogan man this comes up a
lot now because this keeps becoming
relevant
and we had this conversation dude that
was huge that was huge yeah let me let
me help you guys understand because this
tweet's got 34 000 retweets what does
this tweet mean
during the show
i was sitting down with joe rogan vijaya
gaday the top lawyer the one who
reportedly cried at a meeting and jack
dorsey the former ceo
i said
you have banned many people for saying
learn to code
that is an example of your bias but god
i said yes but you need to take into
consideration the context they were
saying that to harass people
i responded with no they weren't
that your interpretation of that is
based on fake news and leftist biased
media
and she said i would need to see an
example of that to which i responded
here's an example
you suspended the editor-in-chief of the
daily caller
for indirectly saying learn to code in a
quote tweet he didn't tweet it at
anybody i'm pretty sure that's what
happened right he didn't tweet it he
didn't directed anybody he was like no i
don't think it was even a quote tweet it
was just a standalone tweet and they
suspended him for it that's right and
there were many other people who did not
direct learn to code
so i say that to her and then well you
got to take into consideration the so so
that was a mistake but the context
around it okay here's another person
who tweeted
a blanket thing like people are saying
learn to code and it's funny banned
so this this cycle goes on and on in
this tweet though i want to show you
some other things because what this
really is about
this is about some shady goings-on we
talked about this yesterday but i think
we've got we have a mystery my friends
take a look at twitter let's pull up the
tweet again on the right side what is
this skateboarding is trending now tim
poole is trending okay i can't do
anything about that elon musk tweeted me
out but skateboarding dodgers at
diamondbacks
now that's interesting now this it says
the black phone is trending that's
promoted
the what's happening tab for me maybe
maybe many of you have noticed this
has been consistently and overtly
political and it's typically leftist
politics it's typically saying something
about
you know it'll say joe biden did not
shake hands with thin air according to
fact checkers that's always what's going
on in my what's happening all of a
sudden it's like you like skateboarding
tim
well i actually do like skateboarding
but you've never recommended that to me
before
something strange is going on and when
you look at some of these tweets let me
see if
i'll pull this one up right here
daily mail reports burning the evidence
before the new boss starts don jr and
right wingers see giant leaps in their
twitter followers after musk bid was
accepted
let me see if i can pull up this tweet
because i might have things out of order
this is a a tweet from me
referencing the red-headed libertarian a
good friend of the show josie her
twitter handle is at t-r-h-l official
that account was abruptly suspended
january 20th 2021 after she
pointed out that in uh january 9th 2019
she predicted joe biden would run for
president and kamala harris would be the
vp
a year later with no warning for no
reason she got suspended
that's it she didn't break any rules
why did that happen well just i believe
it was today she received an email
abruptly they reinstated her account
why
it is obvious at this point that the
drop-off of progressive progressives
their follower accounts are collapsing
and conservatives are rising it is not
organic twitter is lying there there are
journalists in the press claiming it's
oh twitter says it's organic they're
assisting in the lie well
i think i think what they're doing is
they're they're playing a game of saying
it's organic because it's not bots so
it's not bot activity yes it is real
people that are leaving a lot of
progressives are leaving a lot of
conservatives are coming back but the
activity
is not organic the activity is
artificial because this is the ban
hammer which had swung down on people
like josie people like so many others
that are getting these now it's being
lifted and they're magically coming back
i don't think progressives are leaving
sean king wouldn't even leave you know
he deactivates his account whoa whoa
sean king did leave for like 12 hours
right but i mean he came back and then
he came back and then he pretended like
he didn't leave and then
they're trying to call you out jack and
then he was trying to call me out as if
i'd made it up and it's like bro we all
saw you take your account down i'm gonna
say it
i'm looking for the simple solution here
right i'm trying to make the least
amount of assumptions so when i see
you take a look at the the social blade
analytics yeah monday was the day that
elon musk it was announced would
purchase twitter at 2 53 p.m i know
because i was recording live i do all my
recordings for my main show live and at
2 53 the tweet comes out yeah okay
so you mean to tell me the day at eight
eight in the morning when the wall
street journal announced elon musk's
elon musk was in uh
negotiations with twitter like final
negotiations final negotiations it was 8
am not a single conservative said i'm
going to come to twitter and gloat not a
single one came and said let's cheer
this on not a single leftist said i'm
going to leave this is getting dangerous
okay fine maybe because it hasn't
happened yet by 2 53 p.m not a single
conservative joined twitter to tweet we
got it baby not a single one not a
single progressive said i'm leaving i
can't believe this just happened no they
all just for some reason waited 24 hours
they all said you know elon musk got
twitter back i would like to gloat as a
conservative i'm gonna wait until
tomorrow to gloat i think that's because
the news broke the next day overnight
and they weren't responding to him
buying twitter they were responding to
the news telling them to be afraid of it
wrong well social there would there
would be a tiny tiny bump
when i track analytics and i've done it
for like a dozen different accounts you
would think you would see a five percent
increase at least right because this was
trending like crazy every major news
outlet was boom breaking breaking
breaking cnn had it on immediately you'd
think there would be a tiny tiny anomaly
so i gained maybe 1300 followers per day
you'd think monday i'd see 1500 if that
was true ian no it was the exact same it
wasn't until the next day i saw twenty
thousand the next day forty thousand
something happened overnight
and now when i look at the what's
happening tab
yo
now skateboarding is trending for the
first time for me in eight years yeah
i've been skateboarding my whole life
now they're recommending that to me i
want to add something to this
when the progressives are progressives
losing followers i don't think
progressives are leaving for the exact
same reason
you would think there would be a small
anomaly the day the news was announced
of progressive saying i'm going to leave
maybe ian is right that many people
didn't notice until the next day when
the news was really all over the place
but you'd think at least some people in
the know would have left a small
percentage one percent two percent there
is zero anomalous data it is static like
normal and then the next day boom
five thousand followers gone ten
thousand followers gone no i think these
were bot accounts i think twitter was i
i would i would i would argue
it's possible at least twitter was
involved in this we've already seen the
story from judicial watch where uh
the democratic party i think was in
california was requesting censorship how
much do you want to bet that was a dc
draino dc drano that was dcg well that's
his lawsuit okay okay he was censored
after request and i believe i think
judicial watch revealed this we had
thompson i think they did it and then i
know harmy dylan is working on that one
as well where his censoring actually
came at the behest of the california
government and what judicial watch got
was the act whether they're getting the
actual receipts the documentation that
shows that i'm willing to bet
that twitter was operating fake accounts
for the sake of quote-unquote health of
the platform that is the platform was
overwhelmingly being dominated by
right-leaning voices that liberals were
overwhelmingly rejecting wokeness
a healthy platform a good balance
between left and right right well the
problem is former hippie skateboarding
liberal types and left-wing types like
tim poole all of a sudden i said we
gotta vote for trump the scales had
shifted how much you want to bet twitter
said we've got to we have the mission on
our hands so we're going to ban a good
chunk of the right we're going to
artificially inflate the left to fake
the health of the conversation
well i think that almost gives them too
much credit for doing something
that's to the benefit of the whole
and i think there may be an element of
that thought process in there but i do
think there was a big element as in
california of political figures and
corporate figures able to call the shots
with twitter so that some of the balance
or what may look like balance is
actually
influence and i think that's what makes
the case for
twitter not just being a private company
that can make its own policies which is
what people say when there's a question
of do they have the right to censor
people say well it's a private company
it's not really i argued in the last
book that i wrote that it is a
quasi-official public government
organization because of its contracts
because it is beholden to the government
because it fears regulation if it
doesn't abide by certain rules and
requests and it has admitted to
taking directives from political figures
and members of congress
who were not elected by us to control
twitter but that's exactly what they've
been allowed to do let me address that
the path to hell is paved with good
intentions the people at twitter think
they're on a glorious mission to save
humanity
but if you have
the majority of the american people
saying wokeness is not good
and you end up with post-liberals these
are people who voted for democrats i was
i was supporting bernie sanders in 2016
and i did not vote for trump now here i
am having voted for trump and the
republicans in 2020.
that is them saying uh oh something bad
is happening because our worldview is
being rejected in reality they are
insane psychopaths thought
how how do we save the balance of the
system i know as sick as psychopaths we
need to create the perception that
psychopaths are actually normal
they are
just because they have good intentions
doesn't mean they're not doing evil
right so so the path to hell is paved
with good intentions they think they're
good people they're not i can i can echo
that man as a social media administrator
for like six five or six years at mines
you what would happen is you'd get
people would be boosting stuff and
they'd be posting stuff and i'd go
through and i'd be like okay all
politics are not safe for work i want to
keep that conversation in its own area
and then i'd see something would come up
that i would agree with and i'd be like
wow i don't i agree with that and i want
that message to be propagated but my job
as an admin is not to make that decision
i have to put that in the bucket with
all the other politics for instance
tim's work he'd make a video and it
would be cogent and i'd be like well
it's politics so it goes with the
politics and it takes a strong mind to
continuously do that i don't think any
human is really capable of setting their
emotions aside like that let's take it
back in time how did this all begin
gizmodo reported may 9th 2016
former far right gizmodo far right
former facebook workers we routinely
suppressed conservative news
and when i said wow look at this report
from
what is newsguard certified
real news
i get accused of echoing false claims
from conservatives that they routinely
face suppression and censorship and then
every time that comes up i'm like oh
i've never asserted that as a fact i've
only cited gizmodo now of course it's a
fact we have ample evidence it's
happening but the crazy thing is
when the news broke it was gizmodo that
was telling conservatives they were
being suppressed all of a sudden now the
narrative shifts i mean look at their
image it's an elephant with a sheet over
it
gizmodo of all outlets
we know it's happening i think vijaya
gaday may have been crying at her
twitter meeting because they were doing
something unethical immoral or
potentially illegal
and they're about to get caught
i think
that monday night
when twitter learned that so this is
what make this this makes more sense
a lot of people are saying progressives
are leaving conservatives are joining it
is true to a certain degree that many
conservatives are tweeting like look i
just signed up sure unit makes more
sense when the twitter staff had that
all hands-on meeting later in the day
and the ceo said it's happening
let me answer your questions
after that meeting which is now 5 p.m
it's probably 6 7 p.m eastern someone
there said clean it up clean it up clean
it up man you got to get rid of all that
code he's going to come in he's going to
see this we are going to jail dude and
then pulled the code out and that night
boom
josie gets reinstated
all of these learn to code people start
getting reinstated i think they were
running an algorithmic ban on
right-leaning uh users for saying things
like learn to code i bet there was a
list of phrases that yeah that wasn't
the only obvious and overtly
right-leaning i bet you hundred biden's
in there or the hundred by different top
stories
and i think we all know the
pharmaceutical industry there's many
many pharmaceutical interests and topics
that were controlled cheryl does the
pharmaceutical industry have influence
on the media what are you saying what
guys who is this get her off and that
deviates that deviates from the left
right pattern but i think that's another
big one that's at play jack that's
completely not true let me just quickly
say um this episode is brought to you by
pfizer
you see that meme where like every
show is brought to you we're not really
true though
i have to clarify that was a joke
yes we're getting actually brought to
you by
we're just kidding also cheryl can be
pretty sure she can beat us all up what
bothers me is that there's no way to
well at this stage there's no way to
know if there's nefarious stuff going on
in the twitter code i wish that i wish
that we could watch that happen it's
another value of having the software be
free keep in mind they went ahead and
changed stuff really fast is it too late
now did they make changes that even if
someone were to go in and try to see is
it too late look i i said this yesterday
on on war room and i'll say it here
again elon musk didn't just buy a
platform elon musk bought evidence he's
got all this and i guarantee you that he
knows people that he can bring in that
when they actually peel back the curtain
uh look under the hood of this thing
they can go back as far as they have to
go because he will bring in the highest
caliber people because you see all the
stories by the way in business insider
they say oh he's you know he's so
demanding and he's always firing people
no because he wants the best
can i say something if he's really smart
and i think he's really smart
these transactions as you know they're
gone over by attorneys and analysts
some attorney from elon musk's group
sent some attorneys over at twitter a
note that said don't touch them preserve
your records
preserve your records but watch out for
twitter going down mysteriously yep
which of course happens
watch for any kind of server migration
so right now if they manipulate code
i believe it it's theoretically possible
to see that they've done changes to look
at edits but uh correct me if i'm wrong
if they migrate the servers fresh copy
only the existing code all the records
are going to be lost
i don't think i'm qualified to answer
that i don't know
so can i can i just go back real quick
on to the the ministry of truth by the
way because i've just got well let's i
want to bring the story up right now
okay because there's an update and oh my
goodness let me pull up this story first
and we'll throw it to jack we have this
from timcast.com department of homeland
security forms disinformation governance
board homeland security secretary
alejandro mayorka said the board would
work to prevent disinformation campaigns
that target minority groups
they lost twitter and this quickly they
are already trying to play dirty games
we have it over at the daily mail where
they mention it is being head his
abidence is a disinformation governance
board
and it is being headed by a russia
expert who called the hunter laptop
story a trump campaign product and said
she shudders to think about elon musk
taking over twitter
well here's our ministry of truth jack
what's going on well tim see here's the
thing is that nina jankowicz of the
moaning myrtles has has has responded so
she's responded to some of this
criticism she notes for those who
believe this tweet is key to all my
views it is simply a direct quote from
both candidates for you see this was
during the final presidential campaign
if you debate and if you look at my
timeline you will see i was live
tweeting she was just live tweeting she
was just live during the debate
except here's the problem in the
immediate follow-up tweet to this she
wrote
the emails didn't need to be altered to
be part of an influence campaign voters
deserved the context again the keyword
context not a fairy tale about a laptop
repair shop
she called it an influence campaign in
the very next tweet
so we caught her in day one on the job
lying about what she said about the
hunter biden laptop trying to cover it
up but i'm sorry nina
we got the receipts
can i say that i find it a little
odd
that we've all bought into arguing over
sort of the minutia of how this is done
instead of stepping back and looking at
2015
and the notion that anybody should
control for any reason so we're arguing
should they control a certain hashtag
does it really attack people mate wasn't
a tech
why are they controlling a hashtag in
the first place
before 2015 there was relatively little
if any discussion
over bringing in third parties a
corporation no less
to control the content that we can
access and make our own decisions on on
the internet
the social media companies had already
invented tools where we could control
our own experience if you don't want to
see something if you want someone to
call your experience you can follow the
right people you can block other people
the notion that someone else should be
doing that for us
was introduced to us in about 2016. and
we've kind of bought into we've argued
over the terms
we've kind of bought into that there are
reasons why this should be done and
there are people who could maybe do it
better instead of stepping back in my
view and saying
only that which is illegal should be
moderated by anybody in my view well
that's where we've been right so we had
i mean yes
on the show who said here's my rules and
he pulls out the constitution and i'm
like agreed well that's kind of what
elon's saying now that that his his
notion and this this by the way this is
why these two stories are connected
because elon said that his view and he
said this in that ted talk he gave last
week or that it was actually an
interview i guess um that his notion
should be that it should be up to the
laws of the state in which twitter is
operating because those laws are reflect
reflective of the will of the people i
guess if you're in a democracy right um
that being said right that being said
the very same way the ink isn't even dry
on the paperwork for twitter and already
the biden administration is launching a
ministry of truth they know they've lost
this one and they had such power in the
private sector because their sycophants
were just like but it's a private
company
now that they've lost it because someone
had the money to buy it now it's going
government this will be interesting
you'll need you'll need money to combat
this in the courts it'll be difficult
does anybody read are they required to
read anymore
i'm a little older than you guys but
1984. of course yeah an animal farm in
school my kid wasn't
i mean we read it at home i don't think
i was required to no this was required
reading when when i was growing up wow
and when you say ministry of truth and i
get it a lot of people get it i think a
lot of people when i've mentioned these
things about 1984
and how language is used to mean the
exact opposite of what it really is by
the government all the things that are
happening
that are such perfect parallels to what
were written what were written about
decades ago
so many people seem unaware of and i
feel like if people had
been opened up to this they could see it
happening and witness it with some
knowledge that they're not able to in
many instances now right and the main
the main character for those who haven't
read it the main character of 1984 works
for the ministry of troops right that's
his job is to go back in time and censor
things that are no longer in line with
the party narrative the ministry of
peace is all about war the ministry of
love is all about
hatred or whatever they call it double
speak double speak yeah so we normally
save super chats for the end but
typically sometimes we get a good one we
do have a good one here from christopher
who said they're purging their code but
they're bringing back followers to make
their earnings report look good so elon
can't buy now i don't know if that's
true that he wouldn't be able to buy if
the earning report looks good but this
will affect the earnings report if
twitter comes out and says we had a
massive increase of users look at all
this
i think elon musk cornered twitter
he came to them knowing their earnings
report was going to be bad and the stock
would fall
and so they had no choice but to accept
the premium because he made the offer
only a couple weeks before they had to
do their earnings report
if they did not accept the 54 20 cents
earnings report comes out stock drops to
30 the board can be sued for that
massive loss by the shareholders who
would be outraged so he wins this one
they can't break the deal now if they do
they lose a billion dollars but it is
interesting because whatever twitter is
doing right now removing these bans
will make their growth look better
so someone that's not paying attention
right people that are like well i was
unbanned except the report will say in
quarter one we saw an influx of 3.4
million users they won't say it was the
last day that they unbanned everybody
they're not going to talk about how they
got to be careful with fraud if they're
going to try and fraud it's not fraud
it's not defraud their investors by
telling them that a bunch of accounts
that they were they had anyway that they
were considering unbanning before they
just chose to do it to make some extra
money they're gonna go to prison that's
why
that's why they're running around to
everyone in the media saying oh no no
this is organic yup of course that's why
they're making sure to give statements
every single day to everyone else
is not organic that was something right
and they in my opinion lied to congress
when they're like there's there's
nothing in place for censoring these
people or politics it's like bro your
rules outright say misgendering will get
you banned but it's an inversion of how
conservatives see what misgendering is
their rules are overtly targeting
conservatives and they are lying to
congress about it and they're not
getting in trouble i'm looking at the
top 10 owners of twitter it's vanguard
morgan stanley blackrock ssga funds
management aristotle capital management
fidelity management clearbridge
investments it's 10 investment firms do
you know what ssga is
uh no
ssga funds management yeah you're gonna
you're gonna love this wow
yeah look it up what does the ssga stand
state street isn't it
state street globalism so state streets
number four yep so they don't care about
lion economy they're going to send jack
dorsey up there make him tell him to lie
to congress and then he's going to be
the one that's on the hook but here's
something goes wrong but listen what
happens is they give themselves
plausible deniability
they go to jack and say hey jack here's
the report on everything we're doing and
he goes
then he goes to congress and they're
like are you doing this we're not doing
the based on a report he read that was a
lie to him and then he says well they
lied to me i didn't know i told the
truth and the person who lied to me
wasn't under oath
that's the game that's a tough one how
do you how do you navigate that kind of
situation are they claiming really high
paid lawyers
are they claiming net gains of users
because they're also people claiming
they're fleeing twitter but are they
saying that overall they're gaining way
more than they're supposed to be that's
that's the strategy that's what tim's
saying is that the strategy is they can
pick up and far surpass
by removing the bands so it's not even a
political thing in this in this theory
it's just it's about the earnings katy
perry lost 200 000 followers
you're not going to convince me that a
bunch of katy perry fans were like i am
outraged that he must spot the platform
they might she also lost russell brand
more importantly she is she said
that's sad oh really yeah i mean if
anyone's gonna like annoyingly just
leave out of emotion it would be someone
that follows katie no offense kate but
you know your fans are like well didn't
bubblegum barack obama lose you know
hundreds of thousands everybody knows
that those main accounts and elon and
dave rubin had to tweet up today
that the new york times has 53 million
followers and yet gets like 50 retweets
per tweet and elon musk even responded
to that saying what's going on actually
reuben used to talk about this all the
time you call it the reuben ratio right
so the reuben ratio is how many
followers you have versus what is your
engagement meanwhile like you know i can
write something in a certain way
you know or drop receipts on someone
like we just did with guys government
official nita jankowicz um catching her
in a provable lie in a demonstrable lie
and that's going to get tons of retweets
but a new york times article with 53 you
know one percent of that right should be
enough to get didn't he say he could
tweet a celebrity photo and a banana and
it would get more tweaked see i wasn't
going to bring that up cheryl and it did
he did and it got it was like an 80s
sitcom and a banana and he got more he
got like five thousand retweets on it
let me uh actually pull this tweet up
from dave rubin because there's a lot
more context in this we have the tweet
from dave rubin himself he says hey elon
musk as long as you're digging check
into how new york times forbes etc
bought their twitter followers to fake
influence
new york times has 53 million followers
and rarely gets 50 retweets i could post
a banana emoji and a pic of an 80 sitcom
star and get more see next tweet okay
here is dave's next tweet
it is an 80s sitcom star with a banana
and has 7718 retweets god bless her now
elon musk responded i noticed that
i noticed that too pretty weird
everyday astronaut says conversely for
some reason the last two days my account
suddenly got 30 000 followers a day and
we've done nothing different it's far
beyond our average one to two k per day
you're not going to convince me that
that is all organic i responded to elon
musk so elon said almost every media on
earth wrote about me acquiring twitter
causing a massive influx of new users i
just want to point out there was no
influx on the monday this is announced
take a look at this
so social blade is gmt by the way so
that's london time
sure sure so just to take that in
consideration absolutely and it's
possible i was saying that they don't
they calculate everything by like 5 p.m
that still doesn't explain how on 2 on
the 20 so whoever's account that says
every day astronaut right so 3 p.m
look at the averages would be what 8 p.m
on 4 24 3000 on 4253 come on 3 000 on
425 3000 3900 300 700 and then the next
day 30 000. i don't buy it no no you
can't i mean that's what is that uh well
the other way to check is a 10x increase
the other way to check is to check the
create on date
so go through and look because i've seen
a lot of accounts that are created april
22 now with zero followers i have seen
that okay and some people were tracking
on uh governors actually a mainstream
outlet which one was looking at governor
desantis account and they saw that some
but but it was only like 10 of the
followers were created on in april 22.
so so take a look at this 424 it's 37
425 it's 39. now there's a gain of about
just shy of 200
and 160 that can be explained by
uh
it can be simply explained by monday
more people are at work than they're on
twitter but there's nothing
there should be a larger anomaly because
it was 8 a.m on the 25th when they said
elon was in final talks to buy this
shouldn't there be at least a small
percentage of conservatives being like
i'm gonna follow an astronaut
i i would i would think so so i i think
there's something dirty happening but
back to dave rubin's point
let me let me tell you what's going on
with some of these accounts for one
journalists buy fake followers i know
all about that and the new york times
likely has
when when you sign up for twitter they
tell you to follow these people it says
follow these accounts and then you'll
just go boo boo boo
new york times is probably one of the
first recommended and it's i get that
constantly if you scroll back on some so
the way to check um people use this for
identification purposes many times
because typically some of the first
accounts you follow will be
geographically um co-located yeah so you
might follow your local newspaper now if
you're in new york that might be new
york maybe you're in minneapolis you
follow the star journal right maybe
you're in nashville maybe wherever you
are right and so some typically if you
scroll back on someone's twitter
followers those are in um sequential
order so you're actually looking at a
timeline of when they followed each
person and in that time so if you go
back to the earliest ones usually the
first two or three are going to be like
new york times cnn or washington post
because that's what's recommended to you
in many cases when you're signing up for
your account they require that you
follow three before you can sign up and
they present those three to you tim how
do you buy followers we just google it i
don't know if you can still do it but it
was it was library used to have it
remember yeah yeah how expensive is it
kind of they're they're more
they're a little bit more a little bit
more professional now used to be like
these macedonian platforms i'll tell you
everybody accuses everybody else of
buying followers and
you you can't really track this stuff
anymore the the the bot farms have
gotten really good at obfuscating this
um
what people used to do was track
engagement so they would look at a
certain account and then run it through
some you know program and it would be
like 75 of their followers don't tweet
they're fake
and my response to people was dude if
you go to donald trump
and you run him through this you're
going to see 90 of his followers don't
tweet why they're his fans who signed up
for twitter to follow they follow him
they don't post so you can't call people
fake for that so it's really difficult
to know for sure that may be true of the
new york times the new york times might
not be getting retweets because
everybody's signed up because they had
to they'd like to no no no no i don't i
don't i don't comment on the new york
times i follow all these news outlets
i don't engage i see the story and i
click the link i don't there's i'm not
gonna argue with a news article i like
jack what you said earlier about the
real value of these numbers is what is
your follower to interactivity ratio
proven ratio i i in early youtube 2006 7
i started noticing you get 1 000
subscribers you get 8 000 subscribers
and but i was only getting like 4 000
views i'm like where's those other 4 000
people i wish i had a button where i
could
un have a bunch of accounts unfollow me
like unfollow me if they're dead
accounts if they haven't logged in in 30
or 60 days because i need to schlep that
that nonsense number i want an accurate
account of who's really there yes yes
yes but ian
uh i'll give some insights to people who
watch this show we produce this live
show we then produce i think between
three and five clips from the show the
next day and then i have three clips on
two different channels
of those videos
the average subscriber watches 10 per
month
so that means if i'm putting up let's
say eight clips per day for 31 days
we've got
248 clips or whatever the average person
only sees 10 of them
so when i'm wondering
the average follower the average
follower right only sees about 10 of the
clips that i put up every every month
so
if i you know i have 1.3 million
followers on my main on my personal tim
pool channel
i get 300 or so 1 200 300 000 views i'm
not surprised because of those you know
people you can just basically do the
math some people are diehard fans and
they'll watch every video some people
watch every other video some people
watch a video once a week
yes the accounts that haven't logged in
in 60 days that i'm not interested in
having around anymore but
my numbers but youtube does delete those
sometimes but i want a button where i
can manually do it i think i'm trying to
tell you to put it on there man let
people see their real numbers
i mean that can be you're the only one
that wants to see your real numbers i'm
joking most people want to see the big
they want the inflated living on top of
the hill of gold thing it's like you
know if you're going to make that
actually like social currency your
follower number then there needs to be
some regulations about buying fake stuff
it's like counterfeiting money and
telling everyone you're rich
where this comes into an issue is when
when advertisers come up
because if you're using bot traffic and
this was the and i'm going to be careful
about this the previous owners of
newsweek got in trouble for this because
the previous owners before they were
bought out were using bot traffic
to juice their numbers juke the stats
and then present that to advertisers
claiming that they were getting you know
x amount of traffic which was completely
false well so uh back in the day there
was this big scandal around ad rights
distribution or ad rights sales and an
ad right was that
you could have a website that gets a
thousand views per month you sell the
rights to those views to a bigger
network the network aggregates 50
websites that each get you know a
thousand views and now they say we get
50 000 views technically that's true
what was happening was there would be a
company and we'll we'll call it um
we'll call it
golden brand right they're the golden
brand they're the hottest brand they go
to an advertiser look
we get 50 million views per month on
golden brand
now do you want your product associated
with our golden brand yeah then you
gotta pay for 50 million views
and then what would happen is yeah 5
million would be on golden brand 5
million would be on click farm dot
garbage the others would be on ultimate
american patriot dot info and what these
websites would do is
they advertise
you know top 25 celebrities and then
when you click it
it'll show you a celebrity and in order
to see the next picture you got to click
to a new page
turning one person into 25 views
they can then fluff their numbers up
sell to advertisers it was a huge
scandal everybody was doing it you click
those every time don't you thank god
everybody top 25 and the picture they
get you to click on is it in the whole
thing but that's why that's so
aggravating yeah but they didn't they
didn't go through the whole thing right
but that didn't get you to the person
reading one article yes but now one
article or one page becomes 25 pages or
25 but you just answered the question
maybe
i don't understand all this and i get
approached from time to time like
everybody on the web that has a web page
or website whatever and people call me
and say
can i put your website you don't mind if
i put it on my aggregation site right
like this is good for you right i'm like
huh no but you know are they selling to
somebody who's buying ads for them that
what your viewers are yeah if you'll
make a video and this happens all the
time uh the daily wire publishes an
article someone will just quote the
article and then repost them on their
blog called newsjacking right and
they'll do that to try and get clicks
and make money off of it so what they're
doing is they're
in some cases they might be copying your
work wholesale and then wrapping it on
their site so that nobody ever actually
clicks through to charlatan.com
but you're click you're reading it on
you know whatever what tim is in
clickfarm.garbage
and because they never click through to
your site you don't get any of the ad
traffic
is it too far off the beaten path for me
to mention something about we're talking
about ads
i have a website it's pretty expensive
to maintain in my own it's just a little
thing i do my myself nothing like the
big traffic you guys get i'm sure but it
gets more expensive as more people visit
so i let google adsense put ads on there
you know rotate them through make a
little money to pay my one of my web
guys
i got a notice a week ago that said you
can no longer use adsense and i have
violations for factual articles that
they want me to take down but it's not
over that
you can no longer use adsense unless you
approve our new terms
and then there's no way to approve the
new terms
so i had my web guy look i said am i
crazy there's no way to get in to
approve the terms to continue using
adsense to continue collecting off the
ads
and the web guy goes in and there is no
way to approve the term so i'm in effect
locked out of the
adsense cycle there's no one to contact
there's no way to appeal there's no one
who will answer the question
but i feel like there are these sneaky
ways even if you don't they can't pull
you down for blatantly violating
something they say you violated they
find other ways to make it pretty
impossible to operate that sounds like
an oversight developmentally
rather than a malicious attack on you i
can't tell but that's what it sounds
like i didn't read anywhere that anybody
else was usually you can google
something like that or search it and
people are saying that happened to me i
have the same problem
and i just don't see other people having
i i definitely saw some a lot of people
talking about google adsense sending out
new terms um i don't i didn't see
anybody mentioning that maybe if that's
a great question if anyone's in the
super chat who's watching or can send
anything in
um but it that does but it reminds me of
you facebook
that recently said i had a violation and
then if you click in there is no
violation
and it says if you don't fix it we're
going to take down your page and you
click to appeal and it says there's too
many appeals we can't consider yours
it's a it's to me anyway it's a trap
that i can't get out of so i just quit
using my professional face regarding
terms of service this is very important
when a company updates their terms of
service and wants you to click accept on
them what they should have to do legally
is show you the old terms of service and
the new terms of service side by side
highlights of all the changes so you can
click in the areas go right to the place
that's been changed and see exactly
what's been changed
completely unconscionable the way they
do it now let's change it i want to i
want to pull up this tweet from contra
points contra points is a prominent
leftist youtuber and trans woman who
quoted the elon musk tweet of me in
vijayagare and said
the rogan clip he's referencing is about
whether twitter having a rule against
misgendering trans people is quote
left-wing ideological bias
partly true but yes and i wonder if
contra tweeting this earlier today um
with a tremendous respect to
counterpoints for actually knowing the
argument i made and getting that earlier
in the day
natalie wynn counterpoints then says
source
these are the people restrained by the
current moderation that elon apparently
intends to remove says everything you
need to know about the sort of place
that uh this is about to become
i wanted to highlight this
because this from contra points i
believe shows you exactly what the
left's view of the platform is
the cons so when i was on rogan's show
i said your rules are overtly biased
jack dorsey took issue with this and
said no they're not and i said you have
a misgendering policy
conservatives do not agree with
progressives on what misgendering means
to a conservative if someone is born
male they are he him to a progressive if
someone identifies with a pronoun they
are whatever pronoun they want that is a
a difference in world view and at the
very least you can say republicans going
to vote one way democrats going to vote
the other that is not a moral statement
i am not saying it is good to misgender
anybody i'm saying if twitter decides
that the conservative perspective on
this is out the window and only the and
they will enforce with permanent
removals the progressive world view then
there is a biased system to the left
contra points and
the fans of contra points believe it's a
good thing that conservatives are not
allowed to have their world view on the
town square and the largest political
social media platform
now conservatives think the left should
be allowed to have their views on the
platform but the right should as well
i just got to say right there this is
why post liberals people who used to
vote democrat used to vote for bernie
are now finding themselves voting for
trump i'm one of them because i'm like i
think it's fantastic that contra points
expresses
all of these opinions and has left-wing
views wonderful i'd like to argue them i
also appreciate that jack posobik has
his opinions as well but they banned
alex jones they banned donald trump they
banned laura loomer millionops they
banned carl benjamin and for what reason
they said naughty words words they did
not like
well okay that's politics if you want a
political platform expect things you
don't like some people like what they
say vijaya did not
there's a really uh
another response to this wait tim you're
you're leaving you're leaving on not one
but two brothers that absolutely deserve
to have their twitter accounts back
please please remind everyone who that
the krasenstein brothers absolutely the
crisis well but so they were accused of
using bots now that was a bad issue i
don't care
but they should have their accounts back
they accused many conservatives using
bots as well i haven't seen any evidence
you you show me proof the crescent
scenes were using bots i'll say okay
fine for the time being i don't know
about that one of the other responses
was that there were several examples of
uh breaking the rules
that doesn't negate my point
vajayagaday told me that carl benjamin
was suspended
for saying some really awful things and
i'm like yeah i agree i think those
things are really awful too i can't
remember exactly what he said
but does that matter
perhaps there are some people who would
come out and say i don't believe anybody
who opposes free speech should be
allowed on the platform it is an affront
to american culture it is a front to the
founding fathers and everything this
country stands for how about this how
about every conservative who says
burning the flag is wrong
if this platform was run by donald trump
he'd ban people for showing pictures of
burning the flag and that would be wrong
in my opinion but you know it goes to
show you that when they then what if
you're reporting what are you reporting
on antifa
well i don't think
trump would ban you for reporting on
antifa doing it i'm saying
if carl benjamin goes on the platform
and insult someone and calls them a name
so they ban him for it
i believe if it was run by staunch
conservatives people like donald trump
and you post yourself burning a flag
you'd be banned for it but this this is
also my my point though is that
if you're running this through some
arbitrary formula for arbitrary system
you have some machine that's banning
people well right you start with saying
okay i don't like the american flag burn
i personally don't like the americans
like burn up obviously um but then you
start banning people for showing that
well then if i'm reporting on antifa or
if you're reporting on whoever you're
reporting on right and you have to show
extreme symbols so i remember i did an
antifa documentary and uh was it vimeo
vimeo took it down because they said it
was violence well it was a documentary
about
a violent group that uses violence to
attain political end so yes there's
going to be violence in it but let me
say violence again we're arguing
something that
is easily resolved and was in the
original design i think
somebody says something you don't like
you block them once you'll never see
them again that's your
method your tool that you can use
but what you're saying when you want
people to be blocked is you don't want
other people to see it you're not even
talking about yourself you're trying to
control what other people can access
that's what i have a problem with there
are the tools that exist there if i
don't like what you say i can hit block
and i'll never see it again it only has
to happen once avert your eyes and move
on it is insane to me
that the left thinks
you should not be allowed on the
platform if you would choose to call
them something they did not choose to be
called in what
reality
i can go outside
walk down the street and call everyone
uh a chicken effort i can see a guy
walking on the street and be like screw
you chicken effort i know what's gonna
happen nothing now in some places they
might attack you they might hit you for
it
99 percent of the time they're gonna be
like okay whatever and they're gonna
walk off yet for some reason these
people on twitter are like
not even zoobee famously suspended for
saying okay dude
not trying to miss gender by calling me
but being like okay dude like in
response i call everyone dude i actually
call everyone dude regardless of gender
they they are actually arguing that
you would see an image of someone
and because you used the wrong pronoun
you should not be allowed on the
platform right
insane i
mean it's a private private company
owned by a guy if he wants to censor
people and kick them off i get it when
the company well the company is twitter
the
twitter.com is just a piece of property
that's owned by the company twitter so i
want to talk about the product
twitter.com if when it gets big and
you're like okay now this guy is
controlling something that we're using
in the commons what do you do you use
the government to say you can't censor i
don't like that that's the only the only
thing i can think of is to make them
open up the code so that other people
have access to other twitter well i
agree with you i think having the
government come in and say anything it
just compounds the situation that we're
already in
i think that social media titans should
have said
when they were initially approached with
trying to moderate and fake fact check
and do all the things they do
their best answer for their own
protection too would have been to say
we don't do it as tim said gab said we
only censor or control that which is
illegal the other stuff you can do
yourself
and spam
no i don't
did did he say ben spam he wants to he
said he wants to so and so they're
they're interesting and fair points and
authenticate all humans which is
interesting no no i mean i know elon
does i'm talking about turbo oh
gab gab you know andrew torba said the
constitution
you can't dox people and i said i think
everybody agrees with that because
showing someone's address is not an
expression of your political views or
opinions it's just
a you know it's an attack on someone so
should we but hold on
i actually wonder if that uh if doxing
should be allowed well or should
the right to privacy to incorporate
doxing you can't do it well this does
get into though
that the area that we're talking about
where essentially
what elon has said well i just don't i
wouldn't just go with whatever the law
is and that's very noble however
we've all come to agree
that there are certain things that we
want moderated like doxing um that
aren't necessarily covered by the law
yeah like and this is maybe you don't
want to moderate but like white
supremacy for instance you'll you'll go
to twitter it'll be white supremacy
you'll see a swastika which is totally
legal big in your news feed and then
you'll see all these people
tagging you in it that's you and you'll
be like you know this is what would
happen with an unmoderated
open network is and what'll happen is
these people with these really niche
intense powerful even destructive ideas
will go hard on it like all day because
they're obsessed with it and they
destroy the network any ability to have
a normal communication like not want to
be inundated with like
you know political ideology and racism
and all this crap so i get that the
moderator is like we got to stop that we
want to prevent another hitler from
russia
here's here's my um
i threw out a take on this the other day
and it kind of it very much in line with
what charles saying here is that when
the internet was still kind of it's in
its infancy um google used to have this
idea called safe search remember safe
search you know safe search on safe
search off and you always had to turn
off to find the good stuff right um but
what the idea was though the concept
behind that was that
self-moderated content right so if my
kids for example are picking up um like
let's say we're in a long car ride we
try to limit their screen time we don't
do like tablets in the house or like
anything like that but we're on a long
car ride or on a flight or something
right i might have the tablet for them
but i'm making sure that it's on
lockdown i'm moderating that content now
as a dad right i know what sort of
things i'm going to allow my kid to do
same idea is that you go on and then you
can set
maybe you can set certain you could
click i don't want to see hate speech
right and that's a filter and boom you
click that and then anything that
twitter the good people at twitter who
have deemed to be hate speech you don't
see that but it doesn't deny
anybody the ability to use the platform
well that's what i was going to say it'd
be so easy to create a tool that says
if i'm someone i want a third party to
moderate what i can see and i like what
twitter's doing it should be an opt-in
and there can be different things you
can opt in too i i i talked with bill
ottman of mines about this
being of there being the over world in
the underworld and the underworld is
whatever's legal and so if advertisers
have an issue they don't advertise in
the underworld portion but people can
opt in and say i want to see everything
from the underworld or i don't and so
you have your standard moderation
policies you know which is
they you know mines are still very much
a free speech platform that allows a lot
but the real serious nasty stuff that
you might not want to see or the
outright you know hateful stuff
all of that will be considered you know
underbelly versus overworld i don't
think mine's actually doing that well
yeah there's a not safe for work type of
way to view the site kind of like what
you were saying jack a toggle problem is
if someone uploads a swastika and
they're like no i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna self-tag this one it's just i'm
gonna tag it as a dog and then you your
kid opens up the website and they see a
swastika and they're like what so then
you gotta report the thing then it goes
to a group of people or something much
worse than a swastika something graphic
like a body blown open or something it
goes to the the admins to decide like
okay this was mistagged if it's from an
account that consistently mistakes their
stuff you can ban it but that person's
going to start a new account now do you
have to make the user have a unique
email address to start their own account
i think they do it twitter mine's
i think mines does we've tried not
having one of those of course you get
the same guy i'll make 90 accounts and
then upload the swastika on every
account
hashtag dog and you're like wow
so
so getting the community to
moderate honestly
is probably the best way to do it but
they're going to see some nasty stuff
under elon musk's uh rules i'm willing
to bet you'll be freely posting
swastikas
you know what's really interesting too
is that uh twitter banned i'm pretty
sure they banned the american nazi party
do you do you guys remember that i'm
pretty sure they did i wonder if elon
musk would reinstate that that political
well there will be people who will want
to test it and make that point but i
also as as a reporter the kind of
journalism i do
i don't want to see
just the accepted version of something
i'm looking for
stuff that may seem objectionable to
other people because i'm looking for
sources i'm looking for who's saying
things that are off the narrative i'm
finding whistleblowers that way
i'm looking to see what's being passed
around
that may not be true maybe i'm looking
for something that's not true on purpose
and it's become very difficult
whether you're working on the internet
or social media to find the things i
used to be able to find a lot more
easily 10 years ago i just want to say
elon musk is the hero we need and
deserve because he just tweeted next i'm
buying coca-cola to put the cocaine back
in
yo these these are the kind of tweets i
strive for what is happening michael
malus
you should uh you should take you take
heed
do you get the impression like
all right and i'm just gonna like this
this is my impression i've never met
elon um i don't think i know anyone who
knows him or anything like this but my
impression is that elon just kind of
really likes twitter
and
he enjoys playing the game of twitter
and he's talked about this that you know
twitter is like going into the ring
and are going into the arena and
it's like these people came and ruined
the game they ruined the fun of twitter
they ruined the great thing that twitter
was and he's just taking it back because
he likes it so much and he wants it to
be the way it was doesn't he also know
how it is to be an outlier or to be
censored or left out of the i'm not
talking about social media but not being
invited to the white house when other
experts are being convened on something
you're an expert in he kind of
understands that world of certain people
being
carved out or excluded or censored i
think that makes him
someone kind of on the outside looking
in and understanding that's a really
good point
i was trying to pull up a tweet of his
from earlier that i was i was looking at
about free speech i have a feeling that
he's still of the mindset that free
speech means that he has to moderate the
network to allow people to do what they
want but god gives us the free speech
not you elon what we need to do is free
the software code so people can control
their own network
so elon musk uh did i actually lose that
one where is it at here we go elon musk
responding to ben shapiro ben shapiro
said twitter should be uh benchmark
quoting elon musk twitter should be
politically neutral washington post and
every left-wing blue check ree
you guys are giving away your game elon
musk said attacks are coming thick and
fast primarily from the left which is no
surprise however i should be clear that
the right will probably probably be a
little unhappy too my goal is to
maximize area under the curve of total
human happiness which means the eighty
percent of people in the middle
i would like to give a shout out to our
good friend shu on head
who in response to a tweet from elon
musk he said for twitter to deserve
public trust it must be politically
neutral which effectively means
upsetting the far right and the far left
equally shun had said elon musk waging
war on both my friend groups
she didn't respond to his other tweet
saying but those are the least funny
people on this website you need to be
catering to the fringe
i
disagree put it this way i don't i think
what he's saying is unachievable because
you don't see people on the far right
saying that they want people on the far
left band but that's the inverse when it
comes to the far left they do want the
other side banned that's the whole issue
so
to the greatest extent of this you are
not going to be able to get an equal
level of you know quote unquote anger on
both sides it's just not going to happen
you know unless you're adding some like
arbitrary rules on top of this thing
because essentially um the right just
wants to be left alone number one or
number two wants to be able to have an
even playing field the left doesn't want
an even player elon doesn't understand
that twitter's policies that he doesn't
like were specifically to make the left
and the right both unhappy
the left was demanding censorship
they're saying twitter is overtly
supporting white supremacists by letting
them say words can you believe that
people misgendered me
they should be banned and twitter said
okay we'll ban some of them the right
was like well they banned them and i'm
angry but i'll stay on the platform
because i can tolerate views i don't
like
so twitter said how do we make both
sides happy ban a bunch of conservatives
because conservatives can tolerate in
the left camp
if elon musk actually restores free
speech
as he's saying they're primarily coming
from the left that will always be the
case there will be no circumstance where
someone will do something overtly
egregious on the right and the right's
going to be like that's unfair they
should be allowed to do those things
when
okay i'm not going to get into it but
when alex jones right was out there and
across every platform he was one of the
biggest shows he just was and if you ran
tracking on this he was getting more
views a day than i think anybody outside
the mainstream media
i saw lots of people on the right i saw
conservatives up and down um attacking
him for things
mocking him ridiculing him saying they
disagreed with various takes that he had
on various issues that youtube probably
doesn't want me to get into that's not
my point
i don't remember anybody on the right
ever saying that alex jones should be
taken off the air i don't remember ever
hearing that said once
what if conservatives came out
and said you should not be allowed to
have your own pronouns and twitter
should enact a policy that if you change
your pronouns you'll be banned
then they'd become
pretty extreme then you're blown away
hold on there a minute right now twitter
will ban you if you misgender someone
right so i'm saying what if
conservatives said okay we'll do the
inverse
if you use pronouns that are not in line
with your biology we'll ban you
this it feels that is equally as extreme
i know it feels like we're debating who
who should hold the infinity gauntlet
who gets to hold the infinity gauntlet
and everyone knows the answer is no one
you're supposed to break it apart my
point is elon musk is not proposing that
and conservatives are happy
he's saying you can have whatever
pronouns you want but you can't make
someone else say them
and the rights like we can live with
that even though we don't like it and
the left's like no we can't ban them
there's no way that's why you block you
can block whoever you want right but
that makes you you can write happy but
not the left this is the difference
and i've i've had to explain this so
many times with people this is the
difference between cancel culture and
boycotts right
completely different things so a boycott
is when one concerted group says we are
no longer going to support a certain
industry organization company or figure
right uh conservatives i believe right
now are generally i don't know if
anyone's actually said this but they're
essentially boycotting disney right over
the groomer situation that whole scandal
and so that's going on as a boycott but
then i'll always see this and people
will say
hold on hold on i thought you said you
were against cancel culture no that's
different we're not saying that they
should go out of business we're not
saying that no one can do business with
them that's what cancel culture is is
destroying someone's ability to even
have a livelihood whatsoever it's an
inverted boycott yes whereas boycott
just to reiterate uh reiterate is people
saying we all have decided we're not
going to buy from you the cancel culture
is don't let them sell to anyone exactly
but here's why
the cancel culture is afraid that
without that
the popular sentiment would not be on
their side and when we talk about
conservative versus liberal on the
internet for example in social media
i think part of that is because
there's a control issue where
certain factions which are actually
quite small minority in my view of
people
have been able to use social media
in a controlled way to portray as if
a greater section of the public feels
that way
and i think they're afraid if people
were to actually see what percentage of
the public feels a certain way on
certain topics
they would find that many liberals
side along with conservatives on some
issues and sometimes these are very
fringe fringe discussions and issues
getting a lot of attention because the
social media is controlled when left to
their own devices
this stuff would fall along the fringe
it would not look like it does today
with this controlled conversation
elevating certain issues and views to a
level that's far beyond i think what
they really are yeah the bite swa i
think if you've brought this up
is uh what is it mandarin or is that
what it's mandarin for white left it
means white they have a word to define
the white left the white liberals that's
to me
indicative that there's a focus on the
white left the white liberal and then
you start to see the manipulation in the
social media and i wonder how involved
that the the creators of the byzawa are
in
propagating here's here's what happens
here's what happened in in 2014 and 2015
charles was saying when everything was
just open right
twitter at a much smaller user base than
it does today and twitter gained a
massive user base huge influx in 2016
because of trump and because of his
ubiquitous and singular use of twitter
the way he used that platform like no
other person at his level ever had
before right there's always staff tweets
katy perry or um you know barack obama
hillary these are always staff tweets
joe biden right i don't think he knows
what twitter is to an extent or he's
about some website the kids use right
and so
prior to this
um i mean there were really no rules the
idea of someone even being banned on
twitter was almost unthinkable it was
unheard of that people would get
suspended certainly not for speech
anything like this but there was a place
on the internet where crazy people dwelt
and the crazy met with more crazy and
they combined to create exponential
crazy and this is a place
known as the upside down
of tumblr and tumblr
essentially
in that time space through things like
gamergate the sjw wars v and then
eventually trump
came onto twitter and essentially
occupied twitter and specifically
occupied the headquarters of twitter and
by maintaining that
to use a cliche high ground by
maintaining the high ground they were
able to impose their will across twitter
and so something i've been saying a lot
lately is what's going on here is the
liberation of twitter from the tumblr
occupation the tumblr occupation tumblr
occupation
yes let's not forget that after
trump won in that unexpected race which
was unexpected to almost everybody
except i did i was a national journalist
who predicted repeatedly on national tv
that he would win just because i was
listening outside the beltway to regular
people but once he won
the left admitted including media
matters the propaganda group
that they went and held meetings with
facebook and convinced facebook to take
this new tact which was brand new
to do the fake fact checks the
moderations they didn't call them fake
fact checks of course
but the notion that they would have to
come on and prevent something like this
from happening again
that whole notion was raised in a very
organized fashion shortly after the 2016
election going into 2017
washington post
i'm uh i'm just browsing twitter so
there's also a time news article where
they talk about fortifying the election
i think it's for 2020. they were
planning it for a year and a half i
think twenty-one was it was time that
started time time right and that was
talking about it so this is the this is
the great time article that that ian's
referring to
which was essentially that's that's when
the serial killer has you know conducted
their killings that's the zodiac sending
the cipher to um what was the san
francisco chronicle um you know sending
the letter off to let him know let them
know that they needed credit for it it
was something they needed credit so they
needed to know they needed the world to
know and humans have this innate desire
for credit for um for their esteem to be
stoked so for that ego power for that
you know because so many people live off
of ego alone because they're not in
touch with you know as i would say
they're not in touch with god they're
not in touch with the spiritual side of
things and so they live for this world
they're very worldly and they don't
understand
that
uh you know this world is ephemeral this
world will you know we'll leave it
behind but anyway the point being is
that article is a confession it's just a
confession we got you well in terms of
controlling political outcomes and
information
that's just the game for them it was it
was brilliant and like you said they
wanted credit for it
well they got it thanks time magazine
for blowing that one off the people are
the secret history of the shadow
campaign that saved yeah the 2020
election so that's what it's called the
shadow campaign right i just want to
mention it's a moment ago i said i was
browsing twitter and it's because i was
sent a message that tucker carlson was
having a unique conversation uh ladies
and gentlemen i am going to play for you
this clip i just pulled up
tucker carlson some good news before we
go a little justice finally the twitter
account libs of tick tock just surpassed
a million followers on twitter it's
about a minute long i i grant you this
clip from tucker carlson it just aired
tonight some good news before we go a
little justice finally the twitter
account libs of tick tock just surpassed
a million followers on twitter now it
was just last week that the washington
post since reporter taylor lorenz tried
to destroy the person who runs that
account but it turns out a lot of people
actually want the account because they
want to know what their teachers are
doing in the classroom it's not an
attack on anybody it's called
transparency
so tim poole of youtube fame with the
help of the daily wires jeremy boring
just put up a billboard in times square
highlighting what the washington post
tried to do
to the founder of libs of tick tock and
you're seeing on your screen now of
course as predicted taylor loren says
she's the victim here of course
this billboard is so undeniably idiotic
it's hilarious but don't forget these
campaigns have a much darker and more
violent side i'm grateful to be the
newsroom that recognizes these bad faith
politically motivated attacks as a
strong security team so she exposes the
founder of libs with tick tock to
violence but when you say her name
you're a terrorist in other words stop
hurting me she says as she punches you
in the face these people
well this is what they were saying about
vagina right they were saying that um so
was it um
uh sagar and cernovich get contacted by
the washington post saying what was your
intention by including the name of the
twitter official in your reporting and
you're first of all they're all
commenting on this political story that
uh that she apparently had broke down in
tears during one of the meetings so
commenting on that story and then having
elon musk respond to them somehow became
them attacking her last i actually
looked this up earlier today
and a lot of those websites it's hard to
tell when they do these estimates she's
worth anywhere between 30 and 70 million
dollars who is vagina wow 78 i have the
numbers actually right here yeah but
there's each website has like a
different
you know estimation of it so it depends
on which one you look at so i'm giving
the swath right this is a major public
figure who has major control in the
world who's worth tons of money but
you can't talk about her because that's
an attack well walt from wallmine.com
she is has over 38 million dollars worth
of twitter stock uh or
stock's worth over 28 million she makes
8 million a year as chief legal officer
and secretary at twitter it's 7.9
million eight million a year jesus don't
you talk about it ian don't you talk
about her ian well she's about yeah
she's about to get fired and have a nice
package goodbye maybe he'll keep her on
but you're harassing her wow the
misogyny i know her i i only take issue
with the things she's done and said
she's cool here's a prediction
i think if twitter really is allowed to
become
an organic thing
the big story is going to be
how everything changes when you see
it reflect what people really think and
feel
instead of this balanced conversation as
maybe tim suggested
it's not so balanced and i'm not saying
all views shouldn't be heard they should
be heard but i think people will be
surprised how small
some of this group becomes
and how big other groups become that you
haven't heard much
from because they've been suppressed a
problem that comes up on social media
since the beginning it seems like is
that the most popular thing gets more
traction than everything else because it
goes up on trending and then they're
like what's that and then it just
snowballs things like crazy things can
snowball like the swastika hitler didn't
you know nothing that's true always with
unless you do national media unless you
have um like time like chronological
feeds because then you're just seeing
what just got posted by the people
you're following but people can share
so share popular stuff right and then
when they do the more you share it the
more people see it across time you're
right like the most famous people get
free stuff like that makes it so weird
oh i mean look if you're rich the bank
gives you money if you're poor they take
it from you it's same with social media
attraction it's very weird it's almost
like physics i mean look yeah i heard
i've heard the joke where you know they
say when you're rich the bank will give
you money but when you're poor they say
you owe us money and i'm like well
here's why that happens when you have
very little money in the account they
have to pay to maintain it
and so it's draining their you know
draining their uh money to run an
account for you that's not being
utilized enough so they charge you for
it seems counterintuitive if you're very
wealthy you're giving them access to
capital for whatever it is they want to
do and the popular
posts on twitter are getting more
eyeballs on twitter so that's why they
want the popular stuff at the top
similar to having a great big big cycle
so that it's it's always that way
there's some attempt at raising things
up the problem is
twitter wasn't doing it twitter inverted
it twitter was deciding what was going
to be youtube is deciding for political
reasons
if everything was based off merit i'll
tell you
youtube would be a wacky place
all of the thumbnails would be big
tittied women because that's i'm not
trying to be crass that's literally what
it was
uh all of these big creators in the
early days of youtube realize that if i
want views the thumbnails gotta get
people to click on it well wasn't this
another thing where that was the
thumbnail but the video actually had
nothing to do with it exactly yeah or or
what they would do is they'd be like i'm
gonna comment on this video game story
but first yo we got this story about the
supermodel isn't she looking great yes
the supermodel did these things anyway
onto the video games that way they could
justify well i did talk about her
because youtube tried cracking down
saying okay you can't use thumbnails
that do not represent the video it's
causing us problems
so
youtube slowly starts making rules to
try and deal with the insanity that is
this platform
and eventually they say okay the other
problem we have is
people are just posting two minute clips
we need people to post long form stuff
so they make this algorithm that
promotes videos over 10 minutes videos
with high engagement rates and what did
they get they were hoping for game of
thrones they got culture wars
and they don't like it
then they realized hey wait a minute all
of these conservative anti-woke and
libertarian personalities are getting a
lot of traction because people like
their ideas
ban them
and they did this show was shadow banned
uh you could not google search it for a
year and a half
and then one day i mentioned on this
show i was like oh yeah google shadow
band it's like if you if you were to
google the title of one of our clips the
facebook version would come up and the
youtube would not
on google
that seems to make no sense and then one
day everyone's like tim they removed it
you can be searched again
there was a hit piece in the media
and then all of a sudden a wave of
youtubers who were deemed wrong thinkers
were purged from the recommendation
algorithm because someone just said i
don't like it i can't live that i'm like
a peacetime strategist i'm not a wartime
strategist but in my mind i think we
have to build a system where that can
never happen again but then i'm like
well in times of war you have to be able
to censor the enemy at least if you
don't the enemy's propaganda will
convince your people to kill you so you
that's what's i i honestly i think
chinese propaganda is destroying us uh
russia tried they overreact as to what
russia was actually doing but i think
china is actually way more successful
and the reality is
yeah we had an office of censorship in
world war ii because there were concerns
that journalists particularly
would put out information that would
harm the war effort
speaking of that i got this is amazing
life magazine from march 1944
which is i think it's 44 but it's a
magazine from
two months
three months before d-day
in the magazine they show all of the
american military power in the uk
it's fascinating they said the united
states is helping
the uk in the event germany may try to
invade
only what was actually happening was the
u.s was preparing to storm the beaches
of normandy
stage d-day but they could not say that
in the press so in this magazine at the
time they're like we're here with our
military to protect britain
fake news so it was fake news so i mean
this is actually something i studied
when i was in the ic i went through
classes on this um they call it denial
and deception operations so
germany knew that there was an invasion
coming and it was going to be the
americans the question was where would
the origin where would the
invasion come from
and
they conducted so
many deception operations because they
knew
that the germans had spies throughout
europe so what did they do
they knew that they sent patton to
europe because they knew patton they
sent him to the uk because they knew
that the germans would be watching him
but where do they send him
they don't send him across from normandy
they send him to dover now dover is
directly across from calais this is the
the shortest point between on the
english channel this is actually where
the channel tunnel is because it's the
shortest point normandy is where the
invasion actually was it's not where
you'd expect
they send patton over to dover what do
they do
they get
soldiers and they make fake uniform
patches for them depicting fake units
they have these soldiers go into town
and pretend that there's a massive build
up they start renting hotel rooms they
start buying food they start sending
messages they're going all throughout
town and they act as if they're all
members of various units that are there
in the town and yet none of it's real so
the german high command is getting all
these reports back saying hey there's a
ton of stuff going on in cali you know
right across from calais from this place
called dover we think it's coming what
do the germans do
they realize that they can't put all
their eggs in one basket they split the
forces along the north atlantic wall
from normandy and calais the deception
and there's there's way more to it than
this there's so much to get into they
actually
they used a dead body at one point and
they put like fake documents the british
did this right they put fake documents
in the body drop him off of the rock of
gibraltar he washes up on spain the
spanish find the guy they hand him to
the german embassy they say look we've
got these documents see there you know
we know all about this invasion it's
coming and then that makes its way up
hitler
splits the forces
the deception operation was so extensive
that even after d-day
they kept the forces split because they
still thought another invasion was going
to be coming they thought normandy
was a faint they thought that was the
decoy and an even bigger one was still
coming wow it's it's incredible this is
one of the greatest military deception
operations that you're talking about
there that's ever been conducted
you think if hitler wasn't a meth head
that he would have taken the troops out
of calais
well no i mean i think it's game theory
right i think it's game theory that if
you don't have keep in mind this isn't
an age of satellites and
you know thermal uh you know resonance
imaging ir flea or any drones etc so you
really don't know so you're going based
off of you know you've got the enigma
machine uh to send encrypted messages
but that's already broken right um even
though he didn't know that um and then
you've got these human human
intelligence reports so game theory
suggests that if you've got what appears
to be credible information of two
invasion forces you've got to prepare
for both
all right well how about the theory that
and i understand some of this
information has to be controlled
who do you trust to control do you trust
your own government to be doing the
right thing during times of war no
and i'm going back to cnn i worked there
back when it was a news organization in
1990 wow long time ago
and gulf war one was happening actually
1989 i think it was around august when
iraq invaded kuwait and we spent three
years i think doing great coverage
but listening to almost every day saddam
hussein's press guy
give his view
and i think it would be
you know not accurate to say that the
people watching cnn were convinced by
iraq's press guy to take iraq's
viewpoint they weren't but it was
valuable to see
how they were portraying their side and
their viewpoint i think we have a right
to see it i think it's inform it informs
us to see and hear that
and the notion that i've heard lately
that we shouldn't even hear
certain viewpoints or enemies or we
wouldn't want to hear from hitler i'd
want to hear from hitler
i'm not saying that i would want to
believe what hitler says i would love to
hear his justifications and his
explanations i don't think that should
be banned
i mean maybe there's some stuff that
should be yeah the cuties the argument
is cuties like it's so vile that in
order to just to see it is the
corruption so like just to listen to
joseph goebbels speak about the jews was
like enough to be have a a weak mind
corrupted by it so they're like some
people can handle it like you are able
to look at a logical cutie but but but
it's not up to you
to decide
which people can handle it and no wonder
it's children cuties actually had little
girls do yeah that is that's actually
and you could say that what joseph
goebbels was doing was you know vile the
way he was dehumanizing people but nazis
literally no but cuties don't speak
people cuties wasn't speech that's
that's a completely different i don't
know i think a movie could be considered
a form of
no that's actual what about an internet
video of you talking about speech hold
on yes in the film they took little
girls these are real human beings and
they had them perform lewd dances for an
extended period of time and be trained
to do it that is not speech
oh uh well self-expression i'm not no no
no
takes a little girl into a back room and
teaches her extensive lewd dancing so
are you are you suggesting are you
suggesting that imagery is not a form of
speech what are you talking about
because if someone posts a picture on
twitter let's slow down again
a man
several of them took little girls into a
room to teach them lewd sexualized
dancing wait wait don't forget they were
they were paid and they were paid to do
it
that is not speech yeah but i'm not
talking about that i'm talking about the
trail of the movie right we are and
that's the problem
ian i know you are that's not what i
brought up cuties for it's not about
that you cannot
sexually abuse children to make a piece
of speech well showing the movie is not
the abuse they are children
this is this comes up in the child porn
arguments and this was in kataji brown
jackson stuff is that every time you
show the image every time another person
sees it the child is then re-exploited
okay so that that argument could be
taken to joseph goebbels talking about
the dehumanization of jews every time
you listen to him say that he's doing
something
that's that's more than speech no no no
no ian yeah this is the argument anyway
you don't understand
if you go out
and you say
murder is wrong that's speech
okay if you go out
film yourself killing someone and then
show the video saying that was wrong
what i did it's like okay that that
video is a is a is a depiction of
someone being murdered of you committing
a crime that is not speech
that is that is realistic integrity you
as a journalist saw a video of me
killing someone and showed people you
wouldn't be on the hook that's not what
we're talking about i'm talking about
other people showing video that might be
harmful to the mind you you need to i
don't know if you need to censor it but
if you don't the difference between
really gerbils and cuties is that
first of all he was a nazi and the nazis
did those things but if you're referring
to someone who is advocating for
genocide
the question is are they actively
participating in doing it or just
expressing themselves when you're
talking about cuties you're talking
people people who actively participated
in exploiting little girls so talk about
genocide just talking about it versus
doing it
how about this then how about let's
let's take it out of the abstract
facebook said that in certain areas of
europe because of the russia ukraine
conflict right now they are going to
take off their normal ban on calls for
violence as long as you're calling for
violence up to and including murder of
of anyone of russian ethnicity yeah yeah
these are weapons these social media
networks are weapons so they are
basically saying that no i don't know
whether or not that includes genocide
but that certainly sounds like genocide
right if you're you know basing this on
you know someone's ethnicity so facebook
has come out and said we will agree with
this and we will allow this under the
circumstances so correct me if i'm wrong
but i think that alluding to genocide is
legal under for our free speech laws but
as long as it's not an eminent threat
like on wednesday at 2 p.m go do that
then you're not inciting anything yeah
are you just saying i want them to be
gone yep that i believe is legal it is
legal speech so on twitter if that goes
up and then it gets a million retweets
and then all these people are like yeah
i think that too you're creating a
dangerous precedent well this was in the
the the ted talk that that um that musk
was doing the guy interviewing him said
you know some hate speech is legal right
i hate broccoli
right you know i hate ice cream
whatever right like you're allowed to
say that you hate certain things so you
take the emotion out of it so elon i
don't think will he says he's a free
speech absolutist but i don't think
twitter will be absolutely free speech
that's absurd there's nothing
allowed and you going on twitter and
advocating for genocide i do not believe
elon will allow
he's going to be like no because you're
calling for violence and it's just it's
on the line but what happens then when
it comes into the uh the
israel-palestine question because
palestinians constantly say that they
want to see the country of israel wiped
off the map
from the river to the sea yep right and
then and prominent blue czech
journalists have said this yes i was
told that that was a misintermis
translation though they actually want to
legally remove the servers and undo the
country's formation not kill the people
and destroy it all right this is what
haha i think that's his name with the
president of iran for a while was saying
i want israel wiped off the map but he
was saying that he wants it literally
redrawn and taken away because it was
done unjustly not that he wanted to kill
them but the media was like oh he wants
some wipes out now let's make him a
villain and say he wants to hurt people
i don't i don't think there's any point
in trying to dissect the
israel-palestine conflict in the span of
a few minutes too much you know of
course there's going to be a guy who
says this is what we really mean rest
assured the al qasam brigades are not
agreeing with that assessment and when
they fire a rocket out of a children's
hospital at civilians in israel it's
because they want to wipe them out not
just that out of
the basement of the ap's headquarters
where they were at where they were
operating and the ap had an office in
gaza city co-located with one of these
rocket bases and never once reported on
it and this is these are tough questions
some of these are hard calls
but let's go back to the absurdity of
what's become with social media and the
internet
you brought up goebbels
one of the only things i know i was
banned for on facebook was fairly
recently i posted a garbles quote that
simply said something like with no
context
it is quite possible knowing the
psychology of the audience to convince
people that a square is in fact a circle
that could mean anything it could be a
criticism
it could be aimed i knew what i was
aiming it as but i simply did a historic
quote right and i got pulled down my
account
and i thought it was a mistake and there
was no way to appeal and i kept checking
back and a week later i'm back up and i
said
there must have been some mistake all i
did was quote historically hitler's
propaganda saying
that people can be convinced i got
banned again i was gone for another 10
days so you can't even
say something like that tim how many
lights are there in this room
five
but in the lights for four
four nights
yeah so what i do is i like to tweet
under no pretext
shall the right of the people shall the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms be infringed it must be frustrated
by force if necessary
and that's from um
no
hold on uh carl miss jeff remarks that
gets you banned well i i feel like if
you quote the second amendment you might
but if you quote marx you probably won't
so karl marx has the quote under no
pretext shall the workers relinquish the
right to bear arms it should be
frustrating any attempt to take this you
know weapons from the people chairman
mao political power grows in the barrel
of a gun yeah so my point is i mix the
together and i'm like hey look it's not
left or right it's liberty you know but
i guess the authoritarians say that too
and then take your guns once they gain
power
yeah all right let's read super chats if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member why as a
member we will do things like get
billboards in times square calling out
the establishment and uh you know we're
working on some other campaigns we'll do
more culture jamming as marketing and
you will keep our journalists employed
you will help fund the show we are doing
here and you will get access to
exclusive segments of this show we're
gonna have a half an hour segment coming
up at 11 p.m tonight over at timcast.com
members only don't miss it and let's
read what you guys have to say in these
super chats
all right
gone fall says do chickens fart
technically yes
uh usually what happens is i don't know
if it's a legitimate fart but chickens
when they poop
there's like you know
it's it's so it's a it's a shart oh okay
because
you'll hear it when they you know so
chickens have one hole one well that two
their mouth but you know in the back end
one even the roosters it's called the
cloaca yeah so they've got the liquid
stuff the solid stuff and the eggs all
going through the same place yeah so the
eggs often come out covered and you know
i think there was a kid who used to sit
next to me in like fifth grade who had
that
yeah
so sometimes the chickens
the chickens will begin their squat and
you'll hear off
you know so call it whatever you want
and it could be an egg it could be it
could be anything no no the ad he would
be doing that all through class that's
what i'm saying if the chick is about to
lay an egg sometimes the chickens
randomly lay eggs where they stand i
guess it just happens but usually
they'll go into a box and they'll get
ready and they'll like look stressed out
and then they'll start singing you know
so or they'll sing before they do it
it's called the egg song yeah
all right let's grab some more super
chats
sev says shout out to spacex the dragon
capsule is currently docking to the iss
over the pacific
trooning on shabbat pressure
yes elon musk also tweeted about that
that's really cool i love that there was
a um a report that came out that said on
the day that he
purchased twitter he said it was the
same day that he has like a weekly uh
meeting over i think it was with tesla
or some valve issues or maybe spacex i'm
not sure which one but they pointed out
that he went to this meeting at 10 pm
had this super high level engineering
meeting about valves and they're
improving the efficiency
no one in the room mentioned anything
about twitter and elon is just going way
down the rabbit hole of this like highly
technical process
and
folks he's a multitasker yeah he's just
completely able to compartmentalize this
stuff and so his twitter account will
literally be you know
trolling the media trolling the media
trolling the media and then rocket
launch
good for him
all right mini strange quark says tim
have you considered renting one of those
digital billboard trucks to park in
front of wapo
uh and then he says heart andy and lydia
a true wish of happiness and love to you
both and children oh thank you uh i mean
i don't really need to park a truck in
front of wapa or anything like that that
might be a little much but i was just i
was just thinking about this
doxing's free speech
we could doc if if a journalist wants to
publish an address of somebody and then
lie about it why why shouldn't you know
what so i'm mixed on that i was thinking
the same thing i'm not for it but if
these are publicly available addresses
people can type in i think it's
unethical people agree yeah there's an
ethics problem but these journalists
you know taylor lorenz goes on msnbc
like doxing is wrong tweetstoxing is
wrong and then literally publishes lib's
address
and then lies about it now they removed
it after the fact i wonder if it was a
mistake i don't know i'm not gonna give
the benefit of doubt yeah if you've
um i mean if you've committed a crime
the only time that i've ever that i
would ever even say that it's not
unethical is if someone's committed a
crime and you need to identify the
person
um there was this case
you know it's not even political but um
out of cedar rapids this lily peter's
case i don't know if any of you have
seen this horrific 10 year old girl
um
and there were people who based on
facebook were pretty sure that they knew
who the perpetrator was later came out
that it was the cousin who's also
underage really disgusting stuff but the
point is that's not doxing because
that's identifying the perpetrator you
know alleged allegedly that's the thing
if it's just a perpetrator if it's just
a suspect of a crime is it
ethical ah yeah that's tough all right
joshua french says lieutenant jack i am
a is1 retired need to correct you from
the last time you were on you claimed
that the cpo was not an officer a cpo is
a non-commissioned officer and they help
mold the jos
i think everybody knows what i was
saying the difference the distinction
between enlisted an officer oh okay i
mean you can you can be petty about it
if you want but it's it's they get
that's a
pun it's petty officer versus officer
but there is a distinction within the
military ranks of the e-ranks of
enlisted all the way up to the mikpon in
the navy or and then the o ranks which
start at 0-1 and then go all the way up
to the um the cno all right zeke no no
this is james smith says ian i am sorry
for what i wrote in chat yesterday
that's okay zeke i still love no james
james james yeah no problem what did he
say about you i don't know
we forgive you got you back
let's grab some more super chats
john kristen says t-shirt idea that says
freedom of speech is a musk with cartoon
musk releasing twitter birds as doves
it's an excellent idea but i don't think
we're allowed to use elon musk's
likeness for merchandise don't think we
can do that
we can we we can say that we can say
freedom of speech is a musk and then
show
twitter a person from behind throwing
twitter birds in the air well you better
do it because if you don't do it
someone's going to now because that's a
great slogan that's pretty great that's
a really good one oh they can take it
yeah
all right
amber black says the irony of nina being
in charge of the ministry of truth and a
harry potter fan is in the books the
ministry and voldemort censoring news
and speech wasn't exactly supposed to be
a good thing yeah i'm not like i'm not a
huge harry potter person but i've seen i
have seen the movies and that's like a
whole thing in harry potter right it's
the what's the woman's name umbrella
umbridge yeah so she it's like
is this a person who
reads those books
and just totally missed like the point
of so my question actually is now
because jk rowling though of course is
famously
um against the speech codes when it
comes to the trans issue and so
will
this person who's now the head of the
ministry of truth would she ban jk
rowling as a major harry potter fan
because jk rowling does not uh uphold
the speech codes that thomas says
probably tim a uk citizen wanting to
move what state should i move to hmm
georgia
why georgia i don't know it's on the
east coast
what do you guys i mean for a uk citizen
you know i mean it depends on like if
you're looking for
you know it depends i guess what part of
uk you're from right because
if you're from london you might like new
york because they're you know they're
somewhat comparable but if you're from
like
uh if you're from one of the more rural
areas then you're going to want a more
rural area of the united states
oklahoma
oh
it's hot over there yeah
i was in nebraska recently really like
especially western nebraska ogallala it
was awesome yeah missouri there's so
much land in the united states i was in
kenosha last weekend too oh how was it
back to kenosha that town has been
through so much man lost valley says the
left think they're dumbledore but in
reality they're dolores umbridge yeah
yeah that's that's what it is kicked
johnny depp out of the latest one over
amber heard by the way
c uh c scott says new theory the sudden
change to the censorship is due to an
insider at twitter and changed up uh
insider at twitter and changed updated
the source code this is why twitter
locked it down i disagree
uh if somebody at twitter went rogue and
removed the restrictions and so they
locked it down they would have reversed
the change oh yeah they wouldn't have
been like oh no he did it leave it i
guess maybe though
what is this oh my goodness you're on my
siri it's he's he's listening to you
we live in a spy state
that's no joke either that has happened
they just jumped in here
thanks robot with no emotions
the chronicles of chris says they don't
have good intentions just pretend to
their intentions are evil don't ever
think otherwise
amen sometimes their intentions are good
and it's even worse yeah it makes it
worse but i guess what is good and evil
really
well
these people like
for me it's light versus darkness it's
it's sort of like um
it's a combination of things that make
up what is what would be evil or good i
think evil is a combination of things
for these people they are motivated by
their own self-interest motivated by
their own ego and they are willing to
use force and violence and cause harm to
other people these things combine and
i'm like yeah that's evil there's also
money behind it that use those kind of
people that are true believers yep to
accomplish well yeah they're going to
there's tears to this and you've
outlined this in your work that you know
there's a tier of people who are just
kind of hired because they are as you
say the true believers that they're
never going to question this um you know
this is a lot of the frontline people
that you see on tv especially at cnn if
you try to actually talk to them about
any of these issues they would never be
able to have the discussion that we're
having right now
christopher says yes they are purging
their code but they are also bringing
followers to make their earnings report
look better to tell elon he can't buy
now the problem there is if the
shareholders vote no on the sale
they have to pay elon musk one billion
dollars
yeah
so i wonder how much twitter has
available and how bad that would be for
twitter it seems like elon boxed them in
there's no way out the shareholders are
like
if we back out of the deal
we're going to have to pay elon a
billion bucks and then that's going to
cause the stock to tank and that comes
out of operating right but not just the
stock will tank not just because elon's
the deal's done like being canceled but
also because they're losing a billion
dollars and will struggle to operate the
company would implode they have no
choice they have to sell it's
amazing right
js failure says any changes twitter
makes to their source code is tracked by
their version control system github they
can mess with the history but unless
they are very careful it will look
suspicious to an expert i'm just going
to say if they've someone made a change
based on that theory or wrote you know
change back to what's real
and then someone came back in and
changed it back that's gonna show yeah
you're gonna that's gonna leave a thing
it'll be right it'll be logged
uh mikhail isakson says y'all are hornet
twitter is now in the hands of the good
guys and out of the bad guy's hands
swedish deep state the global empire of
wallenberg is crumbling is that what it
is i'm also fighting a sneeze so give me
a
second
there we go
yeah i was like going to sneeze in the
middle of reading well there's clearly a
fight going on i think i i don't know if
i would go i would be so far as to say
that it's completely in the hands yet
and that's what we're talking about
we're also hearing these issues issues
about a potential margin call coming in
on tesla now keep in mind tesla and elon
musk's net worth is directly tied to his
vast ownership of tesla stock i think
something like 20 percent
so if there's a margin call on this
what does that do because those shares
are his collateral with morgan stanley
yep
why does he need collateral if he's got
all that money um what what he doesn't
have the money so that's all it is it's
all in assets it's all shares yeah so uh
grand chi says tim this is quarter two
then reporting in the first quarter
would be enron level good point that was
my mistake yeah any any new users coming
in would be for quarter two not quarter
one so quarter one's already abysmal
all right
pardon will says i created a victorian
era tabletop thought tim cass might be
interested in taking a look before i
publish send an email to spin the ufo
love y'all take a look i saw it
so a lot of people are pointing out i
was wrong
that uh earnings are calculated in march
for the first quarter and reported in
april has nothing to do with the
upcoming report from twitter the numbers
will tell what was in march not what's
happening now
i stand corrected
i stand corrected
sparky says why elon musk buys twitter
now us government needs elon musk for
spacex because u.s won't use russia for
space launches anymore otherwise us
government would conspire to block his
purchase of twitter ah interesting
that's why he's winning
elon i think he really planned this out
more than people realize
well he i think he also kind of realizes
where the chest he's he's fantastic at
always sort of knowing when it's the
right time his timing is impeccable
that he understood that so he threw
starlink up for ukraine he understood
that there was obviously he understands
the space industry right that's the
industry that he's in but it's in
essence it's actually a very small
industry right there's only a few
players you take russia out now suddenly
the u.s needs elon musk
all right
aya bat says it was just revealed this
evening that edward snowden was one of
the original creators of zcash a
cryptocurrency that enables encrypted
transactions i thought you should you
all should know oh we should fact check
that one that sounds interesting
all right
pinch me says tim coffee shop name ideas
tim mafi pool uh no tim offi pool of
caffeine coffee roost
very very nice
yeah michael mouse had a good idea for
the coffee beanie the only problem is
the coffee bean is already a chain you
can't
it's too similar so
you know
a pool of caffeine is interesting that's
nice it sounds interesting i don't know
if it's a good name for a restaurant
beanie town caffeiney beanie caffeine or
whatever i like i like that too yeah
little pressure washing says tim me my
wife two daughters 15 chickens five
goats three dogs one cat all watch you
here are loyal members and proud to
continuously support your amazing work
bro from little tails farm we love you
all over at littletails farm thank you
for your support and uh for your funny
video i think they're the ones who
posted the video where the chicken was
in the window that sounds right yeah
yeah they made a little chicken house
and then like the camera came up and a
chicken's looking out the window
chickens are hilarious man yeah this
looks like from forbes edward snowden
revealed his key participant in
mysterious ceremony creating two billion
anonymous crypto currencies
that's five hours ago
nexpak says we need people who are
unbanned to start doing st uh doing
stuff twitter normally bans
conservatives for i.e learn to code and
see if it still bans them if not then
yes the system is changed and they are
hiding it
and will this have a ripple effect on
other social media platforms
it may
it's going to be
election wizard tried to do that and i
forget exactly what the tweet was but he
was taken down for um
it was it was regarding uh leah thomas
and rachel levine now here's what's
interesting if you this is something
that we noted in one of my group chats
we were talking about this that
if you tweeted right and this is totally
anecdotal i have no idea if this is true
don't mess with this you know mess with
this at your own you know risk whatever
the um you know at home kids thing is
if you just tweet about leah thomas
you weren't getting banned but if you
included rachel levine you were getting
banned and why because she's a member of
the administration uh yep yep very
interesting
all right private a says if you want to
understand how communists are working in
the u.s and beyond look up counter punch
with trevor loudon on epoch tv and
youtube he has obama's roots too
trevor louden is great we did a video
together about antifa a few years ago
all right ron quay says i find it
hilarious that people have been asking
for government help when it comes to
social media buys for years with no
results and now that elon bought twitter
they're jumping on the opportunity
babylon b had a headline um eccentric
billionaire does more for freedom of
speech than the republican party has in
20 years oh yeah yeah yes
raymond g stanley jr says lightly tap
the like button for ian spin the ufo
all right raymond i'm spinning it i'm
gonna spin it with my hands huh oh
that's dangerous you're gonna knock it
off look at that wobble we have we have
some more maintaining we have some more
of the desktop um you know oh good those
keyboard cleaner things
but these are the i got the electric
ones so you know that guy says tim your
billboard just featured on tucker
it's funny that he called you of youtube
fame of you it's like this sometimes
what you do it's so real like you i'm
saying you generally but what we're
doing here and what you're doing is like
they don't know how to respond to it so
that it's almost like it's this this
cognitive dissonance of like accepting
that the paradigm has shifted i
constantly get i've been on tucker's
show yeah i feel like journalist
of twitter
twitter fame like i'm actually just a
human being as well like like do other
stuff of pennsylvania you know what if
what if tucker was like
and a billboard was put up by tim poole
who formerly worked for american eagle
airlines at o'hare
that's true too correct yeah but i don't
know how it's relevant but i guess we're
big on youtube so you know it's not
incorrect in japanese
but i suppose it's good he said it
because people can search for me now
that's true you know so
hold up talk but uh uh
could have had me come on the show
that's not exciting when the shout out
is good enough
i don't know her on the show man is he
in dc does he do a show in dc yeah no no
no he hasn't done a show in dc for all
really no he's out he's like he's lost
he's in la or something um he's got a
couple
places where he goes no it's not new
york as well
he's in a secret lobby
we do know i think a lot of people this
is and it is public that he does um uh
maine actually oh cool uh build his own
build his own studio because he's so
nice up there oh that's awesome yeah up
in western maine and that's public and
i'm not like revealing anything
uh and then he's got another one um and
i'll just say it's in the south but we
do the show uh our show overlaps exact
same so he's at eight to nine right
right you can do like a simulcast yeah
that's what we do with daily wires the
universe we go you could freeze
that'd be so good that'd be really good
yeah we could pre-record yeah you could
brief it we did that with ben we put it
up on sunday and it's actually one of
our biggest shows of the past few months
or whatever it's got like i don't know
600 or so yeah 670 i think yeah that'd
be great yeah we could do we could
definitely do pre-records for sundays
make them longer or whatever
all right ryan grissoff says
to quote the philosophical beanie
aficionado quote now they'll face the
consequences they held themselves above
this is the will of the people aha yes
love it it truly is
all right
probable cause says hey tim sorry i'm
late here's money trudeau violated the
conflict of interest act in 2016. rcmp
said charging a prime minister would
cause damage that it would outweigh that
would outweigh the negative effects of
charging an ordinary person so much for
that higher standard too big to fail
welcome to the real world in politics
man that's how they play these dirty
games yeah right
there was the thing with jacinda arden
as well that said there was some court
decision against her today i need a
chance look into it though
new zealand
all right we got oh yeah yeah that's
right
we got a we got a bunch of stuff coming
in jwm says the big spring poultry swap
at f and farmers market is happening
this saturday just up the road from you
in sharpsburg maryland send someone up
you can get some great content for your
chicken channel oh that's really
interesting
yeah the chicken poultry swap
everybody wants roberto i want to really
watch that video right now like i just
want to see everybody going up to the
poultry swap you would trade because you
want to switch i don't know exactly what
they're doing but i've had people say
hey would you would you trade roosters
right because and i'm like i got too
many ruses already dude
so i think we've got we've got a plan
for roberto he's actually going to be
retiring not to the boy's dormitory but
to a smaller chicken city to go out to
the country with only a few hens and
and live out his days oh that's awesome
yeah retirement retirement we have the
boys dorm which is only going to be
roosters because you can house roosters
together as long as there's no girls you
put a girl in there and they're gonna be
fighting but uh no girls they all hang
out they're they're bros yeah that's
like real life i'm happy roberto that's
uh that's that's a tough pill to swallow
because he screams outside my window
every day
sarah our brahma has two sons and a
daughter who were just born and we
brahmas are large
so all within the first week the brahma
baby was bigger than all the other
babies so we're like he's going to get
really really big and we're going to
have him
you know do the thing with all the
chickens and then we're going to have
bigger and bigger chickens and then what
we're going to do is we're going to pick
the biggest rooster and the biggest hen
and we're going to have a bunch of those
and we're going to okay i just thought
you were talking about cows
and then you mixed it with the chickens
and it didn't make sense oh no no
yeah ketchup brahmas are big chickens
brahmin they're kinda and so then we're
gonna have uh we're just gonna i'm gonna
try and make you know six foot tall
chickens you can ride oh gosh
because a chicken generation is i think
seven months
well well
gmos of chickens yeah yeah basically so
uh super chickens we'll we'll we'll
figure it out
so every seven months we're gonna have
bigger and bigger chickens so maybe in
30 years we'll be riding on chicken back
can you put like weights on the chicken
so it gets builds muscle over its life
like it's like working out you know like
hanging a five pound weight on its back
or something five pounds probably too
much
maybe like 10 10 ounces you know
just like those
those fake chicken arms so it's like
funny but it's also building up his
muscle a little bit
is that abuse to do that to a
non-consenting animal a good idea
probably probably from a non-consenting
animal they're they're animals
it is kind of crazy how quickly they're
born and grow up seven months until
they're adults having their own kids
little brains seven months little brains
little things but they dream chickens
have dreams and you can watch them dream
on chicken chickencitylive.com
there it is yeah they're dreaming right
now
matt nill says tim i live in florida i
listen to irl on my drives throughout
the state as a
truck roving fresh fish governor
desantis vetoed hb 741 which limits the
amount of power a citizen can sell back
to the fpl if they have solar panels
interesting check it
will do
i like the idea that if you if you have
solar panels and you make too much
energy they kick you back some but
there's limits in most places well let
me say this is a topic of my tv show
sunday
in california they're supposedly
reimbursing for the solar at a rate
that's way out of whack with what's
actually being provided
which means the electric customers are
subsidizing the solar customers wow
which means poor people right are
subsidizing the people living in the new
houses that are required to have solar
wow in california
let's see bris bropher says tim and ian
would someone who works with federated
identity protocols such as saml oauth
etc on an enterprise level have a home
with a tim cast team i suggest putting
up a job aboard of some sorts i have not
found one that is a good point yeah
message me on twitter uh or on minds i'm
actually looking for a ux developer that
and also
give me a minute i'm going to go grab
some paperwork that i was writing
earlier and i'll let you know in a
minute
new tech hd says elon's latest tweets
are not free speech absolutists anymore
especially when he says he wants only 80
of the audience
in this controlled opposition is this
controlled opposition to make sure truth
social doesn't succeed and hide the ball
when gop investigations might start i
don't think so
i think uh i think elon is a
troublemaker the simple solutions elon
got mad he was friends with the guys
with babylon b he went on their show
he's a he's a fan of the babylon b and
he has the ability to do these things
and he did it
i think it's
just crazy stuff happening
it is kind of crazy the assumption that
elon because he's super rich must be in
some cabal or something but you'd be
surprised man i've often said it like
how is this show allowed to be
successful well it's because the
establishment isn't as powerful as
people think they are
so we can uh
it's it's nodes i mean there's nodes to
it
a lot of people mentioning carlson
shouting us out very very uh awesome to
hear
ro let's see robo cheezits with a huge
super chat saying i noticed a historical
error on this show a while back which is
fdr knew about pearl harbor this is
false because of the japanese invasion
of the philippines which would cause a
war anyway and it does not make sense to
lose your main battleship fleet right
before a war with the naval power i
agree with that i've heard these claims
that's like oh they knew and they let it
happen and i'm like yeah i've heard
these theories i think you know maybe
they thought maybe they heard but i
don't i simple solutions man well part
of part of it is also so there were
indications that an invasion was coming
one of the issues though and
so the n2 for paycom at the time was
this guy by the name of commander leyet
who later became admiral leyette and
the issue wasn't that like obviously we
knew the japanese fleet was no longer in
tokyo right you know this is something
that i learned when i was navy intel
training so we knew obviously we knew
they had left like we're not that bad um
but the issue was they weren't sure
where the attack would be was it gonna
be hawaii was it going to be hong kong
was it going to be the philippines they
knew those were the big three well what
people didn't what what they didn't
foresee and this is what layette had
said but they didn't listen to him was
that it was actually all three at once
massive blitzkrieg and they said oh
they're never going to attack u.s
territory there's no way that's beyond
their capabilities etc and keep in mind
prior to then uh because aircraft
carriers were kind of the big thing that
and or excuse me were kind of the new
thing that all of naval combat was
battleship based
of course we lost a lot of our
battleships in that but our carriers
were out they used their carriers to
great effect but in doing so that made
u.s naval command have to put more
emphasis on the carriers and really
create that carrier doctrine which is
that what ended up you know winning the
war from the pacific wars let's grab one
more we got legema the gaian saying ian
i speak persian ahmadinejad said
obliterated from the page of time not
wiped off the map the suggestion he was
mischaracterized is widespread but a
bald-faced lie wow
that's even worse
it's still metaphorically liberated from
the con from time like what does that
mean yeah that's erased from the history
books that's he didn't say let's burn
people's body he wasn't like
specifically
he said obliterated yeah he wanted it
gone like obliterated ladies and
gentlemen if you haven't already please
smash that like button do it for ian you
heard him he needs those likes
you know what i'm gonna do with those
likes i'm gonna hire some developers and
make the best technology on earth
all right smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have that members only show coming up
around 11 or so p.m tonight they're
monday through thursday don't forget to
follow the show at timcast irl basically
everywhere you can follow me personally
at timcast if you want to see me posting
weird nonsense on instagram or twitter
follow me
uh cheryl do you want to shout anything
out
well it was
great to be here i'm so sorry i sounded
like this because
i have a lot to say normally
and thanks for having me do you want to
mention your twitter or anything
sure cheryl atkinson at sheryl atkinson
s-h-a-r-y-l-a-t-t-k-i-s-s-o-n
i have a sunday tv show feeds of 43
million households across the country on
all kinds of affiliates abc nbc cbs
and i try to cross-post everything on my
website
sherylackerson.com
all right
thanks
very cool um
human events daily go check it out it's
a podcast for people who don't like
podcasts because we give you everything
in 25 minutes or less i would be remiss
if i didn't mention go and actually look
at the statements that dr oz made in the
debate in pennsylvania this week my home
commonwealth this guy is lying to you he
is a far left liberal this is a vanity
project for him and ladies and gentlemen
look
it's simple
just buy the pillow buy the pillow just
buy it what pillow just buy the my
pillow you know you want one just do it
how would they do that they were going
to do that you know what to do by the
mic no i'm not kidding i'm going to buy
like 300 and i'm going to fill a room
with them let's do it and then i mean
we actually should do that we should
film it
put one behind me it'll be the my pillow
so that'll be like when a guest gets too
unruly they get sent to them my
back here the room back here and then
it's all padded like a padded room we've
got yeah
one of our offices now is kind of vacant
like legit let's let's line the walls
with my pillows yeah and then put like
100 my pillows on the floor yes but
we'll put cameras in and push them in
there and just watch them sounds great
right
and then that'll be that'll be a live
cam too yeah yeah you know and then you
can put super chats into it actually
do you think mike would sponsor this so
we just built a
three foot launch ramp and we've got a
seven foot quarter pipe do you think he
would sponsor sending us a bunch of
pillows for our foam pit
uh that that might take some explaining
yo
we're planning on building a foam pit at
our new facility so the idea is we're
gonna have a stage well that is the
pillows that's interlocking foam and
yeah right so the top layer of the stage
will fold up against the wall okay and
there it will expose a foam pit so you
can launch and do flips and land in the
foam pit i would be so down to make the
phone pit just a bunch of my pillows you
got to call it the pillow pit pillow
yeah the my pillow pit we'll put my
pillow on the side of the my pillow
pillow pit the my pillow phillip
actually not bad that's but that only
works if you go to my pillow dot com and
utilize promo code post over up to 65
percent of sleep like joe biden sleeps
through an international crisis that's
promo code poso p-o-s-o
just to be clear all day every day it's
wednesdays and sundays so we're going to
have 31-foot high ceilings and you're
going to be able to like on the top of
the studio because the student is in the
second floor there's gonna be a third
floor it would be super cool to do a
massive pile of my pillows and have
someone jump like get a pro to like jump
off the third floor and land in the
pillows you'd have to get the highest
firmness of the pillows it could be done
we'll do it we'll do it all right so i'm
excited uh hey guys ian crossland from
encrossline.net if you want to get in
touch and i am looking for a couple of
developers where we have this uh open
source project that we've been working
on a charity that we're building right
now and we're need a couple of pieces i
need like i said earlier ux developer
that can just that wants to commit some
time over the next couple of months uh
donation donate your time it'd be great
get in touch with me on twitter or on
mines and also i'm looking for a project
manager that's familiar with like trello
jira next cloud open source
project management software so that's
something you want to do and you want to
get involved with us contact me mine's
or twitter and i'll see you guys next
time
so fun having cheryl i really wish she'd
been able to speak more we just have to
have you back again that's just the
bottom line you look close enough come
on let's do it again um next week i'm
just kidding we'll make it happen though
for sure you guys may follow me on
twitter and mines.com at sourpatchlist
or at sarahpatchlets.me we will see you
all over at timcast.com for the members
segment but don't forget to check out
youtube.com chicken city subscribe and
literally just watch chickens it's
relaxing though it's like nature sounds
and you can feed the chickens and we'll
see you all over at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out bye guys
you